YouTube is more crowded than ever is it
still possible to stand out and get
noticed I actually had a phone call with
a creator that has 3.4 million
subscribers got it in five months what
are like the first couple moves if
people want to get a head start starting
a new channel at the end of the day it's
all about people the better that you
understand who you're making content for
and being passionate about bringing them
value that's where you can succeed once
I drill down into that I'll come up with
my content strategy
hey welcome back to the Fig media
podcast I'm fired up because we have
derral Eves today author of the YouTube
formula and certified YouTube expert
we're gonna be talking about shorts is
it too late to start YouTube in 2023
what is the latest features and YouTube
news that you need to know what are some
strategies that can help you get ahead
but if you're just me Daryl he is a
father of five co-founder of the chosen
the hit TV show founder of vid Summit
and all kinds of cool projects Daryl
how's it going I'm really excited to be
here doing really good fired up to be uh
back together insane whenever I'm with
you we could talk video I mean I'm I'm
golden yes yes so I'm fired up to dive
in let's just kind of kick it off with
what is your opinion on the state of
YouTube in 2023 and some of the major
changes one of which is a brand new CEO
yeah uh how do you feel about what's
happening on YouTube right now really
stoked with the new CEO I've known nil
for 10 plus years and really one of the
smartest guys in the space and he
actually gets the data side so we geek
out on the data side all the time but um
I believe this is the best time to be on
YouTube uh you know it's very mature the
platform is mature and ultimately some
of the tools that are gonna be coming
out especially with live video and
transactional based type stuff is going
to be very interesting to see how that
unfolds what is your thoughts when
people are feeling YouTube is more
crowded than ever is it still possible
to stand out and get noticed you know I
I think everybody says that every year I
hear the same thing over and over again
and so I actually had a phone call with
a creator that has 3.4 million
subscribers got it in five months five
months and when you're when you're
really breaking it down he's about a
half a billion video views it's like if
that person can do it now why can't
anyone do it and what's crazy is one of
the most overcrowded spaces on Minecraft
and he was able to do it in a Minecraft
space wow which is crazy yeah so so a
new Creator in a short time can start a
new channel and still grow right right
no I I do believe it's based on really
understand what good content is like
right from the title the thumbnail and
then really understanding your audience
what your value proposition is and so
when I was looking at his specific
Channel I was like man he's really good
out of the gate and you know that he has
some pretty amazing engagement when he's
getting two three million views uh per
video release now in a situation like
this kind of brings up the conversation
of shorts yeah was this Creator using
shorts not at all um so this this is all
long form you know 42 52 minute videos
okay is he wow yeah all right so let's
talk about shorts versus medium length
versus long phone length what's your
approach so I think the thing for me is
I actually love short form content uh
you know back in the day when I was a
lot younger I wanted to you know do ads
and so I was always thinking short form
content like how do you really pull
someone in I think it takes a unique
craft to really you know capitalize on
uh that moment of really sucking them
into the message and so I've been a huge
fan I did a consult for Tick Tock I love
the parent company of tick tock about
eight years ago saw what they were gonna
do saw what was happening in China and
I'm like this is gonna be pretty big and
we spend quite a bit of time on short
form content and I I like for me I think
it's just a medium like I think there's
just different formats for different
types of things and it's very very
popular especially with the younger
crowd and I think the older crowd right
now more Millennial and gen xers are
getting more more watch time there
um I think the thing for me though is
like you know I love YouTube and
um I think that anyone that finds a way
to bring the money to the creators is
gonna win and right now uh YouTube did a
really big step which is opening up the
monetization program for a lot of these
short form creators changing even the
policy of how you can actually be
verified and be a partner and a lot of
that money is happening now here's the
thing is the money generally when they
open an upper program uh generally the
money is not good out of the gate they
have to get advertisers to advertise on
the new system and so you'll start
seeing increases of cpms you know over
the over the months and years to come
but at least they made the first step
which is hey we're going to share money
with you instead of just this small
little pool of creators that get it yeah
which is really big it did seem that
even from our test two initial revenue
from short seemed unimpressive yeah and
so your prediction is that it's going to
take time to get buy-in for advertisers
to come in there and do you think it'll
be the leader in terms of platform that
pays creators in terms of short form are
you talking about platform like versus
Tick Tock versus yeah so so the thing
the thing that you got to look at is
YouTube's history so like that's where I
really nerd out I've been on YouTube
since 2005 and they repeat history so
when you go back why YouTube was
successful is in 2007 they introduced
the partner program they they put it out
yeah very specifically with a few
creators and then they open it up for
everyone where you could actually be
part of the partner program and even at
that time uh cpms weren't that good but
it was better than anybody else like is
basically you know a way to share
Revenue where no other platform was
doing it at that time and so as that
matured
um you know you're able to see uh more
monetization opportunities and more
business opportunities for creators and
now it's at really a mature level now
the difference would be is what value
actually YouTube brings the Creator so
YouTube goes out and finds the
advertiser and The Advertiser gives the
opportunity to advertise on the platform
that's the other side of YouTube that
they've been cultivating for a very very
long time and what really took it uh I
would say up 10 notches is when they
started YouTube TV because they're
taking traditional money that was on
television and now starting to integrate
it onto YouTube and also hey we got this
huge packet buy where you can buy online
form you can be on YouTube TV but also
you can be on shorts I mean it's a it's
game over you know and so that's I think
that's the the thing that a lot of
people don't talk about just sharing
revenue is one thing but it's getting
the advertisers to want to be a part of
it and actually put their ads on your
videos and so staying a topic of kind of
shorts versus long form if you were a
new Creator what video length is best
should you embrace all video links or be
thoughtful about going extra long closer
to an hour 8 to 12 minutes shorts or a
mix of all especially if you're just
starting yeah so for me I like to take a
step back and really try to identify the
potential viewer or I call it the viewer
Avatar right of who I want watching my
videos and what value they're going to
actually find from the videos and then I
would actually do a lot of Recon and
research to see what's out there like
what what type of content is engaging
with that type of viewer Avatar and then
once I once I drill down into that I'll
come up with my content strategy and
content strategy of course it might be a
multi-format strategy or it might just
be long form it might be short form it
really depends on the goal that I'm
looking to achieve for me it's just more
can I create value for that potential
viewer that YouTube could say oh my oh
my gosh they liked it they started to
binge watch it there's more people like
them so let's go ahead and serve them
you know more suggested views or get
them on the home page or even on
trending and let's see if we can really
grow and build this and so for me that's
kind of the step that I look at first is
The Who and then I go into the what
because the what is what type of content
would they find valuable and what can I
do repetitively to really engage them at
a very very deep level where they're
they're subscribing for more videos
they're they're wanting to Deep dive
into it and I think one of the analytics
that most content creators Overlook is
the average view per viewer I I like
look look at that data point like a hop
it's like if I can get people coming in
and really binge watching really going
through the process of finding so much
value that the watch three or four or
five videos within it in a given you
know 28 days or seven days or whatever
it may be then I know I found something
that that can be replicated and then two
YouTube looks at the data says oh my
gosh the people are coming on and it's a
literally fulfilling with the two
objectives that YouTube has which is
really simple is like predict what the
viewer wants to watch so okay if they
watch the content and then keeping on
the platform longer and so if they're
keeping on the platform longer and
you're the Creator that's doing that
it's like they're watching and binge
watching and binge watching uh YouTube's
gonna see oh here's a pattern of
behavior there's other people pattern
behaviors like this let's serve your
content out to more people and that's
actually how you grow really really fast
on YouTube gotcha and So speaking of
short form video if you are creating
vertical video what is your opinion on
then Distributing it across multiple
platforms reels right now Tick Tock
right now and the opportunity there yes
so for me there's two approaches once
again is the who like who's who's
watching it and then and then the what
so when I come back to the what is
where's the value proposition now I've
seen repurposed content across all
platforms and some niches work really
well like doing podcast interviews work
really well across you know saturating
across every platform because the value
is in that quick little message are you
gonna go viral with those I don't
necessarily see getting hundreds of
millions of video views but you actually
get the right type of view that you're
looking for and it can cultivate your
brand and it'll put across all the
different platforms but for me it's like
who's watching it so if I have a younger
uh you know maybe a gen Zer that really
really engages with entertainment type
content it probably wouldn't work as
well I think it'd be hey what is the
platform specific because like on Tick
Tock there are Trends having on Tick
Tock that don't happen on on YouTube
that don't happen on IG and the two a
lot of of of audiences shift between
audiences so now let me let me use this
as a clarifier because everyone thinks
oh my audience is everywhere and I don't
necessarily agree with that I think your
audience is a cultivated per platform
and they actually are different I was
out with Mr Beast once and this is the
craziest thing ever he goes hey you're
that guy from Facebook and he's like oh
my gosh wow I like literally sucked down
to a level that I never wanted to be but
it's true this like people watch where
they're at but it's a totally different
demographic and you need to keep that in
mind so to answer your question I really
do think it depends on the audience
you're trying to hit and and looking at
it okay is there an opportunity to
leverage it that way or is it better to
be uh hyper focused and for me I'll
always be more cautious to be hyper
focused because I think once you
understand the pulse of the audience on
the platform I think you can predict
what they want at a more consistent rate
than just kind of blasting it out there
for everyone and just kind of be hit or
miss on on the value proposition as a
business owner that wants to get leads
clients in sales and maybe is more of a
service provider maybe you're in real
estate or a loan officer or you're a
coach consultant what platforms would
you be focusing on would you be myopic
on YouTube or would you take advantage
of some of these other platforms to get
leads strike sales so I I think it's
like once again take a step back and
really look at your customer Avatar and
say okay what are some commonalities I
actually have and get to know basically
demographically where they're at
psychographically what their day looks
like what they do online what they do
offline really get that down there are
certain uh platforms that respond more
to it and it's actually easier to share
it's easier to engage and so I like to
look at that specifically first however
that being said uh nine times out of ten
I'll do it on YouTube and the reason why
is because all the other platforms are
feed driven systems YouTube is a search
and and find right so I mean they
basically uh the algorithm looks very
specifically to predict what the viewer
wants and so YouTube's always surfacing
your content in front of the right
viewer and so that's why I love that
especially for coaches and speakers and
authors and entrepreneurs I love it uh
one of one of my students uh that does
used office furniture Sean like that's
that's his that's his Jam yeah right he
buys used office Furnitures resells fix
it UPS and resell it and you're thinking
okay you know where are you gonna do it
and a lot of people would do ads and
they'd look very specific they'd shoot
cheap things going on Facebook
Marketplace and so on and so forth he
did over 10 million dollars last year
and the only only place that he actually
does anything is on YouTube YouTube
actually found his audience people are
looking for a great review and he does
some really uh great content but what's
crazy is you know you got hundreds of
thousands of dollars of YouTube paying
him to post content about his used
furniture and then he was able to not
only scale out to one warehouse but
multiple warehouses now wow just based
on the demand so so it's also the
opportunity whereas kind of Core
Business was to use office furniture but
you're saying multiple six figures in
YouTube ad revenue is generously I mean
extra income stream a significant one as
well most people spend that for
advertising and yet YouTube's paying him
and he doesn't do any money for
advertising it so it's so great man
that's super uh powerful when it comes
to the future of YouTube and things
creators should be focusing on a Hot
Topic right now is AI yeah what do you
think the opportunity is for creators
using something like chat GPT how could
they use something like that to go
faster improve their YouTube content or
save time so I think there's different
stages and I like I am Pro technology I
love technology I'm a futurist I love
things that are happening that will take
us and Elevate the world to the next
level I do think AI actually can change
the community of any Community uh in a
positive way if it's used for positive
things just to give you an example of of
how AIS transform YouTube YouTube was uh
in in 2012 an algorithm based system and
in 2000 the end of 2012 they did an
experiment where they brought an AI to
try to control everything and that
literally transformed my life and I Know
It transformed your life because now
YouTube is what it is because it's run
off artificial intelligence and it's
really really powerful so for me I want
to take every advantage of uh these
tools but I think you got to know what
the tools are and what they're not if
it's the end-all replacement for you I
don't think that that's a very smart
thing to do but if it's a tool to
enhance your research or to enhance your
script writing or to enhance the way
that you're processing things is great
but at the end of the day you've got to
get it right and you can come up with
all these ideas and you can come up with
prompts that that the AI will actually
help you assist you but I still think
that you need to go through and do some
quality control and say is this really
good for my audience do I need to
enhance it here you you as a Creator
need to create and the moment that you
put that into somebody else's uh
responsibility regardless if it's a tool
or or a person
um the passion's gone and then two I
don't believe that you're actually going
to be talking authentically uh to your
audience are you ready to start or grow
your YouTube channel do you feel stuck
and need help connecting the dots join
this free web class where you'll learn
the step-by-step playbook for YouTube
success we've helped thousands of
purpose-driven entrepreneurs just like
you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at think masterclass dot com
yeah so that's powerful so you just you
just can't there's really no shortcuts
to learning viewer psychology becoming a
better marketer in terms of
understanding positioning of a video
having authentic passion and not just
being a robot and AI might just really
reduce also quality for channels that
only lean on it there'll be a lot of
garbage and so those that are super
passionate create their unique voice
They're Gonna Stand Out do you agree I I
100 agree with that I think uh humans
connect with humans and um I do believe
that uh for you to to be better prepped
I think AI tools can be great for that
and I think even in the future AI
there's some some projects going on
right now that's going to help with
editing and and get the best optimal
things so I think it's going to decrease
the uh the the amount of time in the
workflow and increase productivity but
to see it out absolutely uh erase
everything I just don't see that
happening here in the near future
YouTube 2023 overrated underrated some
different YouTube features and your take
on the on these playlists YouTube
playlist so like the playlist itself
yeah way back when are they overrated
underrated should people be using them
okay so okay so that's a loaded question
for me because I know how YouTube
operates so I'm Pro playlist but I love
when the okay so then let me let me take
a step back because I like everyone
needs to understand what goes on so
every traffic source is controlled by
its own algorithm and the algorithm
actually has a goal that it needs to
achieve and every algorithm has multiple
Bots to achieve what they're looking to
do one of one of the things that they do
is they'll curate playlists like like
the AI will actually curate playlists
through Bots and and review so like if
you go look in traffic sources and you
see oh playlist is bringing the views or
I got views coming from this playlist
generally nine times out of ten this
playlist that you never even created but
YouTube created automatically and then
secondary uh YouTube actually creates
channels too that that are attached to
playlists now they'll include your
videos in the playlist they'll curate it
in a way that that people are engaging
with it that they see oh this audience
engages with it this way so let's go
ahead and automatically create these
playlists and so 100 I I love playlists
when YouTube does it and then I love it
when creators curate content for their
viewer they say hey maybe there's three
or four videos that work really really
well in this order that my audience
would love and they they promote it
organically they're they're you know
talking about it in the video but anyone
that puts like more than four videos in
a playlist I think it's insane uh just
because when I see like at the end of a
video like oh here's a playlist with 165
videos I'm like hey watching that right
like why would I want to watch that got
it but maybe three maybe four you know
depending on the size of the of the of
the videos so a lot of people are
probably using them wrong I would say
that they have good intentions but
they're wasting their time because
they're not using it correctly yes
overrated underrated YouTube stories
once again it depends on the who like I
I get really specific I think it works
really well with certain type of markets
it's really bad with others it just
really depends on the who I would say
not the biggest fan of stories I think
it's just like everyone came out with
stories you know and they're really
trying to Captivate I would rather do a
short than a story any day overrated
underrated YouTube Community tab okay
communities have needs so much help but
it needs so much help I think it's uh
definitely overrated it can still be
used uh to pull content out like one of
the features I love is if I'm trying to
really understand my audience better is
just do these small little micro quizzes
yeah you know surveys it helps me with
the data there but I I can think of at
least 50 different things I could do
with that to make it a lot more better
do you think YouTube will be continually
making Community tab
um I think they're at the crossroads
right now of you know trying to
understand what their platform is what
it's not I think as platforms mature I
think they're going to be more
aggressively of how to make creators
more money uh nil the new CEO has like
been obsessed with that because he goes
hey if we make them more money we make
more money let's figure out the best way
and really pull out any obstacles and so
I think it's going to be more
transactional based and you're going to
see a lot more membership features so
like I think Community tab can be
amazing if one of the tab is really
where they can post uh more like courses
or membership uh differently than just
in the feed for everyone overrated
underrated
super long form content on YouTube some
of my friends like Lewis Howes and Evan
Carmichael are doing two three hour long
videos yep and good and just crushing
what do you think uh once again I think
it comes back down to who's watching it
I mean I listened to three hour podcast
quite a bit Yeah and sometimes watch it
you know so it's just like it depends on
that factor but I can tell you this
YouTube back in November brought out a
report on podcasts it is the number one
podcast a platform in the world it it
hands down beats Spotify like almost
three to one you know and and so just
saying that those are only two minute
three minute videos I don't think that's
necessarily correct I think it's uh
there's a huge opportunity for long form
and then two um I think it's really
important for people to really
understand where the value is that
they're bringing the viewer and
sometimes it is these interviews that
are going to take longer than just you
know 12 minutes or whatever overrated or
underrated live streaming live streams
like way underrated it's like the the
best I've been more excited about live
streams than anything else on YouTube
why is that just is it's a way to
elevate your brand to a level of
authenticity there's a difference
between a perfect polished video that
you put out for everyone but when you go
live you know I I it's just crazy how
you can connect even deeper with your
audience and there's a sense of
community
um let me just give you a perfect
example one of my students she was ready
to give up on YouTube like literally
ready to give up on YouTube and I'm like
why are you gonna give up on YouTube
like this is pretty lucrative for you I
can see how much money you're making she
goes well I hate what I do and what she
was doing is lagging videos she would do
legging review videos like any leggings
that you can possibly go I go the way I
see it is your your channel is more
fashion and you're only working on this
one little thing that you're getting a
mixed audience you're getting both male
and female because guys like looking at
girls and leggings whatever it is okay
you're not doing it right but I says if
you really gear towards you know the
female like a teenage female that really
loves fashion and what they're into you
can really it you know explode and so as
she was able to shift her strategy to
that and was doing more relevant things
just in the fashion space she was
getting like 20x more more views it's
just like it's just so engaging now one
of the biggest thing of connection is
people will love your videos but if you
can jump on live and interact uh with
them it goes even deeper and so once a
month she jumps on with her um with her
fans and answers questions opens up goes
does a little tour type stuff it's it's
not the perfect polished uh videos or
anything like that but um and and two
they're not getting as many views per se
but the the I would say the community
has grown grown so tight because of that
they're anticipating the next video they
care about what she's doing they can't
wait for the the next live stream you
know and it's a great way to to give
back to I think it's to acknowledge that
the people that brought you there one of
the books everybody watching should read
is your book YouTube formula I know
you're also a learner though what are
some things maybe that you think are
essential reading or audiobook listens
for people that want to develop YouTube
Secrets right second edition there you
go I know and uh but in terms of maybe
developing the marketing mind or maybe
some interesting things that people
wouldn't expect that maybe you've loved
that's helped you become a better
Creator yeah I'm I'm obsessed with
learning
um I think you know understanding the
psychology of people will help you make
better content you know predict what
they're what they're looking at there's
a list of books that I can give you I
think the biggest thing would be never
split the difference is
um probably one of the best psychology
books I've read that helps you
understand mindset and how to
um you know really get people to
consider certain things and to take
action in certain things the second
thing is persuasion and I think
Persuasions are really solid book on
understanding how to set up the the ask
before asking about it I know these are
more sales related books yeah but isn't
you know video content really sells
content and totally it's really keeping
them hooking them in and really
understanding how to how to predict it
one thing about persuasion that we found
is there's techniques that that we use
in audience development that kind of
peppers in curiosity that leads to you
know more engagement and then also it's
more audience development in a way
that's like hyper focused let me give
you a perfect example one of the
channels that we own is Matt's off-road
recovery it's as my partner does these
outdoor recoveries you know in his Jeep
you know helping people get out get
stuck or what get unstuck or whatever
it's also we build our our Fleet so
we're building our Fleet or whatever so
he decided to build the world's largest
um off-road wrecker okay and and so as
he's building it he's he's saying you
know maybe I was thinking about doing a
competition what do you guys think you
know just engaging with the viewer and
they're yeah you should do it and like
who who you know these are the the
creators who should be a part of it well
we just did the biggest outdoor event in
Utah wow just just the biggest door
event in Utah yeah and and it was our
event we we basically persuaded people
that we were putting this on were the
bigger biggest YouTubers that have these
Wreckers are coming and competing and uh
it was amazing it was like literally
amazing and it was all done because the
community wanted it number one number
two it was a persuasion technique to
help them because we were going to do it
anyway we were kind of like planting
seeds to get back to ramp up to it
exactly got it and so they're more apt
to you know take four days off their
their life to come watch you know
outdoor Vehicles Rock call and yeah to
do these recoveries in some pretty uh
crazy areas that's awesome final
question so it can feel overwhelming to
start a YouTube channel
um there's so much to learn and know you
and I have been hanging out at events
like VidCon you've been on since 2005.
my first channel I ever started was from
a church in 2007. so it's funny because
what have you been on YouTube 18 years
yeah yeah is that I mean from the
beginning yep and so you know a lot of
the stuff comes natural to you but
there's so much solar there's so many
details in the algorithm and the whole
thing could be overwhelming and if
someone's listening to this podcast
they're they're plugged in they're
learning but yet it still can feel
overwhelming there's a lot of
competition what are are like the first
couple moves if people want to get a
head start starting a new channel that
maybe most people wouldn't think about
yeah it's all about people like at the
end of the day it's all about people the
better that you understand who you're
making content for and and being
passionate about bringing them value
that's where you can succeed I think a
lot of people are looking oh I'm going
to do this because it has a whole bunch
of views or it makes a whole bunch of
money and like is that the best thing
for you really you know it's just
looking at what you're passionate about
and then is there an audience that
actually exists online which nine times
out of ten it does you know it just it
it basically does and can you provide
value to that audience and I think if
you do that I think you can succeed and
so uh my quick tips is to really
understand who you're making content for
uh do Recon and research to see you know
are there communities on YouTube are
there communities on these other social
platforms out there what are the videos
that are really performing you know that
have a whole bunch of views and last six
months I really look at really high
views low subscribers that just tells me
the topic is really good or there's
something in that video that's really
engaging I like to curate uh outside of
my own vacuum chamber what channels and
videos are performing really well and
then I like to analyze like why do they
choose this title why do they use this
thumbnail what are the patterns of the
hook are the hook the same what type of
video are they shooting is it raw is
authentic is it multiple camera you know
where's where's the production on it and
then I try to really look through a lot
of the comments to see where the like a
small subset of viewers you know being
engaged so much that they take time to
actually leave a comment and I want to
see hey is this really hitting oh at the
same value proposition if I ever see a
Time code I'm like okay that's cold for
me because something really touched them
enough to time code it a Time code from
someone else leaving a comment exactly
exactly and so for me I'm looking at all
those things and then I and then I take
a step back and say okay if I'm creating
content here's all these ideas is that
work in the last six months around the
same vein can I create content in in a
unique way and what's my unique value
proposition what's going to make me
stand out above every everybody else
like because if you're going to just
re-hash everything else and you're not
bringing your own uh God you know given
you know gift that God gives everyone
that that individuality of your content
then I think you're going to miss out
and I think a lot of people uh miss out
because they either try to say oh I'm
going to create content and they don't
even think of the viewer they just
create content and they don't really
look at it through the vein of someone
watching it and I think that's a huge
mistake and then two I do believe that a
lot of people look to Outsource to
someone and say okay go ahead and do
that and I think that's a big mistake
too I think you just need to see hey I'm
passionate about this this is what I'm
gonna do and I've done my research now
I'm going to actually grow by making the
most valuable content for this specific
Niche derral Eves bringing the fire and
of course check out the show notes for
all the list of the books and resources
as well as what do you want to shout out
we'll link everything up in the show
notes how can people follow you what are
you working on right now yeah
derralives.com pretty much just my whole
life right there like everything I do I
think the big thing for me is I actually
uh like you said as co-founder I am
co-founder of the chosen we're just
getting ready to start shooting season
four so if you haven't seen it it's
pretty amazing you can just spend the
reach of this project uh half a billion
so far half a billion viewers of watch
viewers some Amazon Netflix yep some of
the seasons are on YouTube yeah peacock
and peacocks crazy just absolutely wild
so the chosen of course you could check
out and then chosen.tv if you go there
you can find all the all the details
amazing so check it out of course you
can connect with Daryl we'll link it up
in the uh show notes Daryl Eve thank you
they do